[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> So what is FGM?
It's very simply the removal of a girl's external
genitals, the
clitoris, the labia, and in severe cases,
the wound that's left is sewn
up so there's only a tiny hole left.
It's done simply to control women.
It predates religion, it's not done for religious
purposes.
Parents to do it because they feel that their
daughters will then be
married.
They don't do it just to inflect pain on them.
And it's an incredibly difficult social issue
that has to be changed
through talking with communities.
And what you're seeing there is the most intensive
form, which is
called infibulation.
You can see the impact this is going to have.
Basically you're closing up and sealing the
entire genitals.
What happens as a result is that a women's
virginity is ensured, that
she will remain chaste so her husband knows
that fidelity won't be an
issue.
It's a very, very complex issue.
Yet it's also very straightforward.
[MUSIC PLAYING]